hello readers let's talk about poems
poetry is a special kind of writing if
ordinary writing is like talking then
poetry is like singing poetry is a way
of making art with language
poems can express huge ideas or feelings
they can be about the sound or rhythm of
language or they can be goofy little
jokes it's like any other kind of
writing poems can be about everything or
they can be about nothing at all they
can be funny or sad or sweet they can
rhyme they can very much not rhyme
and all of that is in my opinion
absolutely wonderful
i think of some poems as condensed ideas
that contain a lot of ideas and small
amounts of text so every word matters a
lot
those are little light bulbs
representing ideas so i'm going to look
at a couple of poems today in order to
describe some parts of a poem let's
begin with the poem cat by marilyn
singer
goes like this
cat
i prefer
warm fur
a perfect fire to lie beside a cozy lap
where i can nap
an empty chair when she's not there
i want heat on my feet on my nose
on my hide
no cat i remember dislikes december
inside
so the person who wrote this poem
marilyn singer is the poet for stories
the person who writes the poem is an
author but for poems the writer is a
poet but who is telling the poem who's
speaking
the person whose voice we hear in a poem
is called the speaker
which is another thing i like about
poetry when you're having trouble
understanding a poem read it aloud
part of the pleasure of poetry for me is
hearing the words bounce around as you
say them and in this poem i'm pretty
sure the speaker is a cat
now you'll notice there are only three
sentences in this poem but they're
separated into 15 lines
you can see these lines have anywhere
from one to four words in them lines can
be as long or as short as a poet likes
but here the poet is creating these line
breaks to indicate pauses and rhythms
right like normally we wouldn't start a
new line here if this were prose which
is what we call all other forms of
writing prose uses normal sentences and
paragraphs right the the poet is
choosing to create line breaks in order
to change the way the sentence or the
line looks on the page
poetry is not just about how it sounds
sometimes it's about how it looks as
it's written
now in addition the poet is also using
spaces to scoot these three phrases over
as well as this word inside the words
themselves are scooted in they're curled
up and feeling cozy like a cat by a fire
in the middle of december you'll also
notice that some but not all of the
lines rhyme with each other and let's
take a moment to think for a second what
is rhyming really one way to think about
it is when the ending sound of a word
matches the other ending sound of a word
like lap and nap or when a bunch of
sounds match each other throughout a
pair of words like remember and december
i want to be super clear about this part
because i was already out of high school
before i learned this thing but
poems don't have to rhyme
they can but they definitely don't have
to
i have one more poem part to describe to
you and to do it i want to use billy
collins poem litany which sounds like a
fancy poem at first but then becomes
much more conversational i'll end by
reading the first three stanzas which
are these paragraph looking things not
all poems are broken into stanzas but
this one is
so those are some parts of the poem to
review a poet
writes lines the place where each line
ends is called a line break and a group
of lines together in a paragraph is
called a stanza
the voice that tells us the poem the
poem's narrator is called the speaker
some poems rhyme others don't
cool
here's a snippet of litany by billy
collins
litany
you are the bread and the knife the
crystal goblet and the wine
you are the dew on the morning grass and
the burning wheel of the sun you are the
white apron of the baker and the marsh
birds suddenly in flight
however you are not the wind in the
orchard the plums on the counter or the
house of cards and you are certainly not
the pine scented air there is just no
way that you are the pine scented heir
it is possible that you are the fish
under the bridge maybe even the pigeon
on the general's head but you are not
even close to being the field of corn
flowers at dusk
there's more but i'd love it if you
looked it up and read it aloud yourself
you can learn anything
dave it out